And everybody, this is Dr. Cutters again, and we're going to talk about the physiological
web of Hashimoto on really, really what I'm trying to do here is to drill into you,
the fact that you, this is more complicated than most doctors understand.
So I'm not trying to make you a practitioner, but you really have to become your own practitioner
if you're really going to help yourself.
So this gets a little heady of this video, but stick with me, it will help you just ingrated
you, that you have to look at a three-dimensional picture where you're looking at your Hashimoto
disease.
So clinical priorities are, you know, are you stable or is your disease fluctuating
between hyper and hyp, we talked about that on the last video?
Because the patient have appropriate hormone replacement, whether it's drug replacement
or whether it's nutritional replacement, is it balanced?
Do you feel like you're balanced or are you bouncing around, feel like you have no control
over this?
Are you identifying the triggers, your different lifestyle triggers, your different food
triggers, the sugar imbalance issues with, are you dealing with hypoglycemia and hyperblycemia?
Are there other antigens and pathogens that are triggering you?
Any chemicals or pollutants that are triggering you, hormonal triggers, all the different triggers
that we've talked about through this entire course you have to look at?
Have you investigated different nutritional strategies that you could help balance this
out?
And what are some mechanisms to help you deal with this tolerance?
Because when you're dealing with any autoimmune disease, it all goes down to immune tolerance,
having to have that balance.
Dr. Dittis Kratzi really is my mentor with Hashimoto disease and he said, this is a great
quote.
If you can only understand the pathophysiology of Hashimoto's in a linear pattern, then
you're going to have great limitations in an appropriate clinical balance.
It's a matter of fact, you're really never going to be able to really help the patient
that is really struggling with ongoing autoimmune issues because it's not a linear disease,
it's a three-dimensional disease.
However, if you can understand the pathophysiology of Hashimoto's as an integrative web complex,
then you're going to have a better chance of managing this.
So to change this words here, to help you understand this is your responsibility to understand
this web.
So we're going to get into some depths of all these intertangled webs of Hashimoto disease.
It's not just a thyroid condition.
So overlapping physiology responses with Hashimoto.
So you got the green box there, the center of this slide, Hashimoto, immune reaction, how
it affects your immune system.
You can have a triggering event going up on the slide causing an increase in inflammatory
cytokines causing TSH suppression and decrease activation of thyroid glands, stimulation
and hypoeitivity.
That's the most common scenario with Hashimoto's, a hypothyroid symptom pattern.
You can also have that increase in inflammatory cytokines causing significant thyroid gland destruction
like a spurt of destruction and a spill of thyroid hormones from the thyroid gland in a hyperactivity.
So we talked about that where you can almost get like a Graeme's disease-like symptom with
heart palpitations and like it's crawling all over you and feeling like you got the EBG
so that you could just take place for an hour or just a couple minutes or a couple days.
Then you can go to the right there.
You got a triggering event.
Notice in the red here, the triggering event.
Could it be I was exposed to glue, could it be I was exposed to glyphosate, could it be
I was exposed to different chemicals, mold issues, I ate something that had high glutamate,
whatever it was, increase inflammatory cytokines and this could affect the thyroid receptor
expression and hyperactivity or going down on that chart, it could downregulate the enzyme
that converts T4 to T3 and I end up with a decrease T3 production and hyperactivity.
Or going to the left, I could have chronic destruction of my thyroid gland and just significant
loss of thyroid sites over time.
Those are the cells of the thyroid gland so I just have the inability to make thyroid
hormone and that's just a progressive problem.
So clinical parole, many Hashimoto patients develop early neurodegeneration and brain inflammation.
If you haven't watched my video on brain inflammation, a couple modules back, make sure you go back
and watch that video.
Talks about microglial primate and 1M2 states of the microglial cells.
Very important because this ties directly with Hashimoto directly.
So you can get microglial primate for a lot of reasons if you go back and watch that video.
I didn't even mention on that video that Hashimoto's is a direct link to microglial primate.
We really talked about microglial primate with post-concussive syndrome.
We talked about it with pathogens like Lyme disease and things like that.
It damaged the blood-brain barrier and heavy metal toxicities.
But we didn't really touch on one cause of microglial primate is Hashimoto's.
Because Hashimoto's autoimmune reaction on the brain is one cause of microglial primate.
So you can have Hashimoto's affect other parts of the upper border neuron center and it's
causing increased antibody production on multiple areas that affect the brain directly.
TPO antibody can have a cross reaction to the cerebellum.
So remember we talked about cross-reactive foods and we talked about how glutein peptides
there is a molecular mimic to the thyroid gland.
Well TPO antibodies have a molecular mimicry to the cerebellum.
The cerebellum is the back part of the brain that controls your spine and eyes and balance
and coordination.
Also your posture and coordination of all the paraspinal muscles.
So it's not uncommon for somebody especially a young person with Hashimoto's to have scoliosis
because they have a disc coordination of the paraspinal muscles causing the scoliosis.
It's not uncommon for someone with Hashimoto's to have that cross reactivity with the cerebellum
and end up with cerebellar autoimmunity and they end up with poor balance issues.
They stumble a lot, they trip a lot, they have vertigo issues, anxiety and crowded places.
Nausea with movement, they end up with driving in a car, things like that.
So you always want to look at TPO antibody production if people have car sickness and sensitivity to sound,
sensitivity to light, these all can affect, these all can be effects of inflammation in the cerebellum.
So from an exam point of view, this is where it's good to get to a functional neurologist,
not a medical neurologist, a functional neurologist.
That's where somebody's going to test you for a taxi and Robberg's test.
That's where Robberg's test is, you're standing up, feet close together and you close your eyes,
does you fall to one side, don't try to do that on yourself because you could fall over and hurt
yourself. But that test is for when you, you have a lot of, your eyes are a receptor,
your eyes are feeding back to the cerebellum so you can tell where you are in space.
When you close your eyes, you're totally relying on your cerebellum to keep you upright,
to keep you balanced. You take away that reception from the eyes and you close your eyes,
you really notice the attack, the inability to stand upright and to walk upright and to walk
without falling to the side and such. And you notice the inflammation of the cerebellum.
So what's called, also you can see from an examination finding a terminal tremor.
So these are, these are key findings when you're looking for Hashimoto's reactivity and
gliandid sensitivity. So these are also connections with gluten sensitivity as well.
So when a person says, I don't have any issues eating gluten, my stomach is just fine but they're
starting to develop a terminal tremor. Their ataxia, their balance isn't as good. They end up with
a wide stance gain because they don't feel secure, their stance anymore. They don't have the same
coordination or they're losing coordination. This is very serious things. There could be damage
to the cerebellum that is, that is, you know, not good. So Hashimoto's affects the brain, affects
the cerebellum. Hashimoto's antibodies also affect another part of the brain in A here on this
diagram. Those are called astrocytes. Your astrocytes are a type of gruel cell in the brain.
Talked about it a little bit on the video on brain inflammation. Your astrocytes actually do a number
of different things but they, one of the things that they do is they form the blood brain barrier.
And TPO antibodies can attack astrocytes. So literally Hashimoto's can cause blood brain barrier
permeability. Also, TPO antibodies can affect myelin, she cells and they can affect and see
there the synapsis and affects synaptic activity of your dopamine, your serotonin, your acetylcholine,
and your gamma receptors, all your receptors in your brain. So here's the web of Hashimoto's and
neurological dysfunction, a lot of information here in the center. Hashimoto's can cause,
go straight up, cytokine activation of the neuroglial cells, the glial cells, the cells in the
brain, causing in the red there, neuroinflammation, brain inflammation. What's brain inflammation do?
Go back to that video again, causes activation and priming of microglial cells. Remember once
microglial cells are primed, they never go unprined. And they can stay in that M1 state and be
kicking out inflammatory cytokines and cause all sorts of issues in the brain. Neuroinflammation
will cause neurodegeneration. Neuroinflammation will cause blood brain barrier permeability because
there's damage to the astrocytes. So you have an increased blood brain barrier permeability. So
not only do you have issues because of the TPO antibodies, but now you have things getting across
the blood brain barrier that never should be getting across the blood brain barrier and even
greater chance of primed microglial cells. And worst case scenario, you end up with antibodies
to neuronal tissue. So that's what you would test for in a Cyrix Array 7 and a 7x is antibodies to
neuronal tissue. Also with cytokine activation of the neuroglial cells, you can have an altered synaptic
activity and decreased plasticity of the brain. That means you don't have the same connections
and ability to make new connections in the brain. Your ability to learn and ability to remember what
you learn decreases. Back to that center, Hashimoto's hypothyroidism to the left, increased TPO antibodies,
increased gluten sensitivity, causes cerebellum cross reactivity and cerebellum destruction that we
talked about in the last slide. And then you go down impaired thyroid activity to the right,
causes synaptic issues and affects your dopamine receptors, your serotonin receptors,
your acetylcholine and your gamma receptors. You can have down regulation of those receptors
and down regulation of the neurotransmitters themselves. This is what could lead to, you know,
all sorts of mood disorders that are diagnosed, you know, as a mood, different mood disorders.
And you end up with some medication for that mood disorder, whether it's anti-exiety medication
or depression medication or whatever, and it's really stepping from your Hashimoto's.
So impaired thyroid activity going straight down affects axon-gragine, again impaired plasticity.
Remember brain plasticity has to do with brain remolding, learning new pathways. This is what
has to take place on a constant daily basis in your brain and when you lose that ability,
you start to have memory issues, brain fog, inability to remember things, inability to
learn new things. And then to the left tissue swelling, peripheral nerve entrapsements,
and you get these weird symptoms that you never even associate with Hashimoto's, like you've got
neuropathy, but it's actually Hashimoto's neuropathy, thoracic outlet syndrome, nerve entrapment syndrome.
How could that be possibly related to Hashimoto that has to do with upper motor neuron inflammation?
And literally with neural inflammation and microglial primate, depending on where it is in the brain,
you could have symptoms anywhere. If it's in the parietal gland, you're going to have symptoms,
you could have pain symptoms or in your foot, and you think you've got something wrong with your
foot, has nothing to do with your foot, has to do with the neurological map
in the brain, the parietal lobe of the foot. So you got inflammation in the area of the left foot
of the right parietal lobe, and really the inflammation is the right parietal lobe, and you feel it in
your left foot, there's actually nothing wrong with your left foot. If you understand what you're
dealing with causes of upper motor neuron lesions, meaning lesion just means something going on,
this case inflammation, upper motor neuron means brain inflammation, neural inflammation,
in the brain can cause issues anywhere, anywhere that that nerve, that brain connection is
connecting to and communicating with the part of the body that it's communicating with.
So it gets extensive. So this is just an neurological web, so there's a lot more to go here.
There's a web when it ties to the gut function. So autoimmune thyroid disease affects the
microbiota, and back and forth, affects the sex hormones, affects thyroid physiology, affects weight
issues, affects diet, and iodide, and all sorts of things. There's key connections to all of this.
It affects your liver, it affects your gallbladder, and we're talked about a little bit before in
another video about causing gallbladder sludge and gallstones, but it gets worse than it actually affects
bile production. And if you've got to read my book of the seven phases of detoxification,
then you understand that phase four bile production and gallbladder function is one of the
main phases of detoxification. It is a main issue. The web of Hashimoto's and the gastrointestinal system
is equally as complex as the neurological system. It can decrease the intestinal motor complex activity,
meaning you have slow flow of all your organs. It causes decrease in gallbladder contraction. That's
what leads to the sludge and gallstone formation. It also decreases your ability of your liver to go
through phase one, phase two, phase three detoxification because it's basically a dam in the stream of
that flow. It can lead to bile duct backup. It can actually lead to more serious diseases of the
pancreas, pancreatitis, and even bile duct and pancreatic cancer. So this is very serious issues,
not trying to scare you, but the altered microbiota affects everything. The altered intestinal growth
and T cell regulation, your immune system in your gut, and decrease your ability to feel
leaky gut. It's just it's very complex. I don't want you to think it's a thyroid disease.
Sorry, but it gets worse. Hashimoto's also leads to a diminished insulin response and a glucose
response. This is where it ties to a person's difficulty in losing weight because you end up with
increase insulin receptor site resistance and increase susceptibility to insulin resistance
in general. This what leads to further cycle this this like negative loop of immune activity and
increase immune response at the cell membrane itself. So again, it's not a thyroid disease.
The web of Hashimoto's with liver function, your hepatic function, Hashimoto's will decrease oral
tolerance, will affect hepatocyte function, will alter peripheral thyroid metabolism.
When you're talking about hypometabolic activity in the liver, it's going to affect phase one,
phase two, phase three detoxification pathways, and decrease clearance of hormones, hormone
metabolites, pollutants, chemicals, everything that you're trying to get rid of through detoxification
pathways through the liver. So we talk about in the region's course, defects on phase one, phase two,
liver pathways, causing slowing of those pathways, slowing function of those pathways,
whether you have the genetic defects of those pathways. We didn't talk about how you could have
perfect, you know, genetics on phase one, phase two, cytochrome P450, pond one pathways,
you're not one of two pathways, but if you have decreased thyroid hormone, it's going to slow those
pathways as well, and it could cause the same problem as if you had a whole bowl load of genetic
defects on those pathways. Hashimoto's affects the female endocrine system, it decreases, it could
cause abdominal menstrual cycles, it could cause infertility, it could cause miscarriages,
it's not just what I'm trying, I'm not trying to scare you and cause depression in these
sides, but I've tried to give you some peace of mind that you're not going crazy, this causes so many
issues, and you have to look at so many triggers, and the farther you can, it's kind of like what I
talk about with the region's course, if you can step way back from it, and look at it from a 30,000
foot view, you're going to have a better ability to handle this disease, and it's the same thing
with thyroid issues, if you could, and literally all autoimmune issues, if you can step way back and
look at all my possible triggers here, this is a good slide to just download and memorize, all these
different possible triggers, and there's probably 50 more that we could put out here, that you've got to
look at, and if you can start managing these and look at it in these web entanglement, you're going to
have a much better chance to take control of your life and get yourself in a state of remission
with Hashimoto's and improve your life greatly, as I always keep studying, I'm here for you, we're here
for you, and we're praying for you, we're going to keep working through this.